un président en pâtissant compréhensif à
l'ecoute si vous êtes menacés tels que
vous l'écrivez par pouvoir politique ça
fait partie des situations d'état qui
sous couvert par le désir en visitant
des centres d'accueil en rencontrant des
demandeurs d'asile emmanuel macron a
voulu montrer son côté humain il a
annoncé que l'état prendrait désormais
en charge les repas et a demandé
d'accélérer le traitement des dossiers
sans doute pour faire taire les
nombreuses critiques que suscite sa
nouvelle politique migratoire
mais sur le fond le président de la
république reste ferme
il y un devoir d'humanité mais il ya
aussi le devoir de respecter la loi de
la république
le choix de calais pour la visite n'est
pas un hasard ville symbole du problème
migratoire
c'est ici que s'était constitué la
jungle un campement illégal où
s'entassaient huit mille migrants
désireux de se rendre au royaume uni
démantelé il ya plus d'un an le camp
n'existe plus mais l'attrait de la
grande bretagne est intacte ce qui
pousse des centaines de migrants à
revenir dans la région mais les
autorités veillent pas question pour
emmanuel macron de reconstituer la
jungle à calais n'est pas une porte
d'entrée dérobée vers l'angleterre et je
veux être ici très clair cela continuera
à être le cas beaucoup d'associations
d'aidé aux migrants ont choisi de
boycotter la rencontre avec le président
pour protester contre l'attitude des
forces de l'ordre vis-à-vis des migrants
bon nombre d'entre eux se disent
victimes de persécutions
le policier nous arrête une frappe et
nous tabassent les ong dénoncent par
exemple l'emploi de gaz par la police et
la confiscation presque systématique des
tentes et des couvertures
l'oeil vraiment un recul
ce qui est incompréhensible c'est
vraiment digne du harcèlement des
agissements qui feront l'objet de
sanctions si elles sont prouvées a dit
le président mais dans son discours
prononcé devant les policiers
emmanuel macron a surtout vanté leur
travail avec les migrants leur
promettant une prime pour les
récompenser ici jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris